thank you view covers to London
comic-con today kind of a combination
because I'm the whole sort of group
theme is there you take an Iron Man suit
and give it sort of characteristics of
another comic book character or just
kind of famous character in general so
we've got Iron Man which for the shocker
from spider-man
we've got mixed with Sabretooth from
x-men and from our predator from the
film series so yeah it's been good fun
the inspiration to come like that today
I'm pretty much the sort of a I'm not
sure if you've seen the sort of
photoshopped images going around of like
Iron Man paint it like a different kind
of character pretty much that we just
want even boomer so they look really
collect really badass so I see if we can
try and do a soft rock version of its
costume together cuz it's looking pretty
great thanks it's uh it's it's easy that
it looks but it's not where your walk in
the park but it's not as sort of a
mind-blowing feel might think it's like
there's a file cool pepakura which
essentially is like a paper craft
program cut out in paper sort of and
just translate over to different
materials like I've made mine out of an
Eevee a foam essentially just gym mats
from like PE and that kind of thing and
yeah it's a sort of different kind of
materials mashed together and yeah it's
just a lot of handiwork pretty much do
you have to kind of work out how are you
gonna put it together yourself or is
there any sort of plans and stuff that
you look down line and what a lot of it
for me my brother hair came from Tim Mir
putting us in the right direction to
sort of have our YouTube tutorials were
just Internet videos in general showing
us how to do it or some of its kind of
sort of common sense problem solving if
you're doing sort of custom builds like
three of us are it's not all gonna be
out there you go through just some of it
yourself but primarily you get your
grounds going from tutorials and things
like that it's a good fun and what is it
about Ironman that you like particular
he looks amazing he is one of the
coolest looking characters in comic
books so they translate that over pretty
well you big fan of the film's then yeah
I mean I love the films I mean I was
never big it's my Marvel but it was more
towards the sort of our cartoons TV
shows I think I was never read the
comics but uh it's always the cartoon to
me and I ma'am was one of those can you
put your helmet does we can get the full
of fat
guys you've both look absolutely
fantastic
I mean how what is it like under those
costumes lightweight but uh very
uncomfortable that's very hard with
amount of people that here just have got
to walk in these you have to kind of
make sure that you've got enough room to
walk by and stuff we try to but it's not
gonna happen this maybe I'll lose my
depth perception I keep knocking into
people cuz there's how far out my
shoulders are going but no one seems to
mind just yet I have about you you wanna
tell me a bit about your costume as well
oh yeah it's it's a mixture between
Ironman and I've mixed in a sabertooth
from x-men because normally same tooth
has like a yellow and sort of like a
ready brown color but because I live
with the guy that's got yellow suits
often get confusing I went for more of a
Hulk vs. Wolverine color scheme we sort
of got like brown and light brown what
is it man Iron Man that you particularly
can the x-men as well x-men because it's
just well when I was younger is off the
first real thing I watched on TV and I
thought it was amazing
and yeah just the idea behind everything
to me and I like the idea of having more
mutants and stuff it's really cool into
a cool concept and Iron Man just because
the whole everything so mechanical and
very cool about putting the costumes
together a little bit we sort of put it
together with Eevee a foam it's
essentially just gym mats you come up
and you position them in a certain way
put them together
Ouiser there's a program called pepakura
which a second papercraft program people
make a 3d object program turns it into a
net you then put the niche together and
you've got you know well are you've got
a helmet or whatever you want to have
built on how you've been doing walking
around like that at the event today it's
been really good fun I mean the
reactions you get from people make the
whole sort of costume building very much
worth it because the actions from
everyone is pretty insane everyone seems
to well 97% of the audience seems to
like it or the 3% so I think it's best
to bid that I really understand where
the idea comes from there you just put
your helmet down and we'll have a quick
look at your costume
fantastic I'll see you brilliant thank
you so much and if I ask you about your
costume who are you combining with Iron
Man today a man and the predator from
the movies they why predator an Iron Man
is that looks pretty cool so how did you
put it all together because it's pretty
big isn't it yeah a lot of its from the
pepakura files and then then other bits
who've just got a sort of improvised and
just cut and shut other bits so yeah
it's all basically EBA foam with the
occasional bit of resin bit of polyester
body filler have you do much cosplay
before yeah a couple of times did a fair
on guard from Gears of War so yeah that
was a pretty big one last year and then
other ones like crate dos and Shao Kahn
from Mortal Kombat
what are you enjoying about being at the
Comic Cons today and the reaction you've
been getting and it's good this is it's
good it's a nice little legal trouble
juniper you held on so we can have a
good look at what you look like in all
your splendor oh it's a two-man job this
one
Wow that's quite something
looking pretty badass
I've seen brilliant thank you very much
you